very um tight-lipped to my team so far
you haven't given very much away before
coming on this morning you're not
fancying a crack at the job are you no
no i won't be running um the
the thing i want to see out of this i
mean look
this is probably the most unpredictable
leadership election in history
and but it's also one of the most
important
because if we don't get this right we
are going to lose the next election
we're going to be out of power for a
long time
and so how do we get it right i mean
first thing we're going to do is go to
avoid
any more
ethical uh problems uh i mean if we have
another
integrity problem in the next six months
or so
we might as well forget all the policy
issues all the terrific leadership all
the great um
uh
the great uh eloquence that grant champs
has just been showing for example
uh because it won't work and so that's
way way way the most important thing and
i think you know it's a bit of a pity
it's a very fast campaign because i
think all of the candidates have to go
through the ringer on that uh secondly
what has some competence this government
you know this government has i'm afraid
i mean it partly because of cove it's
not entirely its own fault but you know
passports getting you getting your
passport getting your driving license
getting a gp
appointment all those things is
somebody's got to take a really hard
grip of it
uh and the the third one is is the one i
think which will probably already been
on your or your station i haven't seen
this morning which is the issue of the
policy we've got the wrong economic
policy it's demonstrably wrong you know
we're in recession and it's got to
change and so that's and and the people
who come up with the best alternatives
there are going to be most important so
who do you who is your eye on them well
i haven't i haven't finally decided yet
i'm down to about
two or three i'll make up my mind in the
next few hours but i've got some facts
to check first so i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna well you you'll then ask me what
the fact is or will you give us a short
list then
come on
the the ones the one the ones i'm
thinking about
grant um
uh
jeremy hunt
uh and liz trust those those are three
they're all that they all want they've
all got some experience right they've
all got a degree of experience which is
very important competence they say is
critical
uh the uh the ethical issue is a bit of
a problem if you've been in the cabinet
for the last year i mean bear in mind i
called for
uh i call for boris to go in january not
not out of some sort of sudden surge of
blood to head but because i've worked
out that this this disaster that we've
now witnessed this death of a thousand
cuts that's what i said on the day is
going to happen and so you they're going
to have to explain that but also make
sure that there's nothing else for them
to get wrong um
and they're they are people who
see that we need to change the tax
policy the it's not just the tax policy
truth be told i mean the harsh truth is
that the treasury in the bank of england
have got inflation wrong badly
uh i've got the tax taker wrong we are
the re the reason we've got the biggest
tax burden is not just that they put in
those policies but they didn't actually
realize quite how much tax we taken out
the british people quite big errors for
a government to make at the same time
right
you know you're talking about inflation
and you're also talking about tax cuts i
mean tax cuts
fuel spending which fuels inflation
right no that's not right it's very bad
economics i'm afraid it's astonishing
that that so many commentators have not
published i'm not just you i mean you
know really sort of theoretically
economic commentators said that it's not
true i mean what's happened at the
moment is vast amounts of money being
taken at the economy by two high taxes
and and very high prices being sucked
out of the whole economy which is why
when the tax increases were due to buy
it was the first month that we had a
downturn in the economy up until then we
have been doing better than germany
france italy over the course of six
years and then suddenly wallop down it
goes now in the middle of that you've
got kovitz so it's a slightly doubtful
uh slightly double set of numbers but
the the argument is wrong what we have
to do is to bring the money supply under
control put interest rates up that's
quite painful
and of course control the domestic
pressures this the summer of discontent
we've got coming really really tough
stuff and it's going to test the courage
of of any new
uh leader and that's the other thing
that we're talking about character
really
i'm on earth taxes it was quite
interesting i thought talking to grant
champs who was pretty clear that he
would pay for tax cuts by cutting
government spending
do you have any concern that there's an
awful lot of tax cuts being thrown
around uh this morning alone uh by some
of the uh candidates and how do you fund
it well some of it and there's a mixture
of things and yes look
every every every candidate will tell
you more efficiency we've been saying
that yeah i mean that's very if we could
work that one out then you know we'd be
moving away it would have been simple
yeah um uh every candidate will tell you
you know that they're gonna cut this cut
that now what what what's problematic
number one
the treasury got very badly wrong the
financing of the covert spending it's
been about 400 billion and it's
basically on a floating rate it's like
it's almost like on an overdraft
uh they should have laid down war loans
for that you can still do it to some
extent it's twice as expensive now as it
would have been but you can do that not
pay off over five years which won the
issues i have with liz uh but over 50
years you know that's that's that's a
that's a real issue you should do that
you've got to focus the tax cuts on
things that will deliver growth
because
um there is a trade-off if you if you
put taxes up so much that you cut growth
you actually then end up losing tax
revenue that's precisely what the
current trade reports go through now and
then you've got to bring some of these
things under control and there's no
doubt about it there's none about that
um we're out of time but just before we
go and what would be your one bit of
advice to the candidates you've
obviously run in a leadership contest
yourself be straightforward don't don't
over big yourself up for you know i mean
we're hearing all sorts of
uh sad stories about people's poverty
stricken background were people who are
probably richer than i could ever be in
a thousand years so uh be be
straightforward
don't try and make imaginary histories
and focus on what's right for the
country okay thank you very much david
davis